I'd like to now show you two
mathematical facts about how we
integrate quantities of motion.
Suppose we have an object, let's
call this the i hat direction,
and it's moving, and it has
an x component of velocity.
And suppose it starts
at some initial position
and goes at some final position.
And in the initial
position, it was at time ti,
and the final position
was at t final.
Now, we have two very
important integrals
that we want to look at
which govern how we describe,
how we integrate acceleration
with respect to time,
and also how we'll
integrate acceleration
with respect to space.
Now, recall that our
acceleration, which
may be a function of
time, is the derivative
of the x component of
velocity with respect to time.
So, let's first look
at a simple integration
of acceleration with respect
to time and see what we get.
So, if we integrate
acceleration,
now I'm going to introduce an
integration variable, dt prime.
And our integration variable
goes from our initial time
to some final time.
And if we use our
fact that acceleration
is the derivative
of the velocity,
then we can write this is
dvx, dt prime, dt prime again.
After a while I'll drop
the dummy variables
and the endpoints
of the integral.
And this simply
becomes the integral
from t prime, t initial.
t prime equals t
final of dvx prime.
Now notice we've done
a change of variables
in the integration.
So instead of now talking
about the endpoints
of the integral from
t prime, t initial
to t final, now what we're doing
is we changed our integration
variable.
And so what we have is, we
have the velocity integration
variable is going from
some initial value.
And that integration variable
is going to some final value.
So again, our initial
conditions may
have some initial velocity
and some final velocity--
three different
ways of describing
the initial and final states.
This integral is a very
straightforward integral,
the x final minus
vx initial, which
is the change in the x
component of the velocity.
And that's our classic
result that we've
done that the integration
of acceleration
with respect to time is
a change in velocity.
Now, let's see what
happens as a comparison
when we integrate our
acceleration not with respect
to time, but suppose that
it's a function of space.
And so now we're
integrating again.
We have a dummy variable.
We have to be
careful, because this
is the x component
of acceleration,
but x prime is our
integration variable,
and that's going from
some initial position
to some final position.
Now, we can write this as
again, make the substitution,
dx dt, dx prime, going from
the initial to the final.
But now notice we're going to
rewrite this integrand as dvx
times dx prime, dt prime, dt.
And when we do that, we have
this result that dx prime,
dt prime is precisely
what we mean by vx.
Now, I'll introduce some
dummy variables there as well.
So what our integrand becomes
is dvx prime, vx prime.
That's not a function,
it's a product
of a differential
times vx prime.
And now our new
integration variable
is going from some initial
value to some final value.
Once again, this is a
straightforward integral.
For those who haven't
seen integrals like this,
it's just something like
x dx is x squared over 2,
but our integration
variable is vx prime.
So what we get is
1/2 vx final squared
minus vx initial squared.
And so what we see here is two
fundamentally different facts
that if you integrate
acceleration
with respect to time, you
get the change in velocity.
But if you integrate
acceleration
with respect to space, you
get 1/2 times the change
not of velocity, but
of the x component
of the velocity squared.
And both of these facts
are central to how
we'll analyze the
concept of work
and how we applied
Newton's second law.